foreign
Battleground Paris
for hours police and protesters charged
against each other in the French capital
Kurdish demonstrators are angry at
Authority's response to the attack on
Friday which killed three refugees
they want answers from the police why
did it take so long for them to respond
to the attack why have they not
designated this a terrorist attack and
why wasn't security provided to the
cultural center after it had earlier
been asked for
we've been working on the 10th
anniversary of the killing of our three
comrades ten years later we the Kurdish
women are still asking for justice and
now again our blood is spilled in France
we are angry and the French state is
responsible
they refused to remain confined to one
square where the police allowed them to
protest Kurdish demonstrators say the
bullets fired in the attack were felt by
every member of their community
as the protests have calmed down here in
Paris the police and security services
are out in force clearing the protesters
from the street going from Republic
Square to Bastille square but the anger
in the streets of Paris continues
as more videos emerge from Witnesses
some show onlookers overpowering the
attacker security sources say he still
had multiple magazines and dozens of
rounds of ammunition
Eunice witnessed the attacker targeting
the cultural center a restaurant and the
nababu's shop he says the 69 year old
man knew where he wanted to open fire
the state want us to believe it's a
resist attack but the guy was released
from detention 10 days ago in 10 days he
found guns and came here we want to know
we want the state to answer
the killings have touched a nerve among
France's migrant communities with
protests in other cities as well they
want to know why an attack on a minority
Community isn't being designated a
terrorist attack
these kids chanted and called for
revenge and unless the government can
satisfy their demands their anger is
unlikely to go away
from Paris